the industry is very fluid I mean that's
one thing about this business a very
fluid business I think a lot of the
paradigms that existed in the 80s and
90s in terms of fashion marketing the
roles of runway shows outdoor visual
advertising campaigns like billboards
and the such the costs associated those
things print campaigns no different than
any other business those those don't
give the return on investment as they
did in the 80s and the 90s and I think
the recession has many brands at all
tiers of distribution all price points
rethinking how to deliver better value
and how to be aspirational but less
indulgent less self-indulgent less self
important I think brands that are very
self-important kind of look down their
nose at their consumers if they're
smarter than the consumer and the
consumer joins in the club and buys the
brand that that is a dying you know
ethos I think you're looking at a much
more kind of responsible generation much
more constructive much more how to
consumers want to demystify how the
business is that they support or
operated and that's changing fashion
dramatic